[Музика]
привіт привіт, хлопці, настав час уроку англійської,
мене звати Наталія давайте давайте
почнемо, тому ми продовжуємо розмову про
спорт і сьогодні у нас дуже
цікавий урок давайте почнемо з нашого
домашнього завдання я попросила вас написати текст
про себе  і ваш улюблений вид спорту,
давайте подивимося, що я
підготував для вас на основі ваших відповідей, тому подивіться
на текст, хороший це текст чи ні,
оскільки ви бачите, що речення різного
кольору, але вони також перемішані, щоб
літера чи ні  текст не в порядку,
тому що ми бачимо початок
тексту, і ми бачимо кінцівку, тому
текст згорнуто, все перемішано,
давайте пошкодимо, я б хотів, щоб ви
подивилися на текст і швидко записали,
вам не потрібно  запишіть кожне
окреме слово, просто схематично
згадуйте початок тексту та
кінець тексту Зара Боскович Magisto
chakra qu e Visser tweetable Aska Regina
Baba
[Музика]
[Музика],
тож давайте  перевірити так а  Ви бачите, що текст
правильний, тож давайте прочитаємо його привіт мене
звати Кейт мені 12 років я
студент, я люблю спорт і добре
танцюю, але до цього я був спортсменом,
це було важко, я танцюю  кожен день,
починаючи з 2018 року, коли я говорю про професійне
спорядження для моїх спортивних занять, я
завжди ношу легенди і футболку
після того, як закінчив урок спорту, я
зазвичай їм банан, займаюся спортом, їж
здорову їжу та вивчаю англійську, тому
що це важливо,
найкраще, Кейт, тому давайте мати  подивіться ще
один приклад, це буде від
хлопчика, давайте подивимося на текст привіт мене
звати Алек, і ви можете прочитати текст, але, як
ви бачите, є деякі помилки, тому я
даю вам 20 секунд, перегляньте
текст і знайдіть  помилки тут,
давайте перевіримо разом, так що привіт мене звати
Алек мені 11 років я вчитель чи можете
ви бути вчителем у 11 років ні, ви
не можете, так що це помилка, яка
правильна відповідь
я  студент я учень я хлопець
це теж можливо добре давайте далі я
люблю  спорт і я футболіст, але
до цього я був спортсменом це було
важко будь-які проблеми тут я не
думаю так,
так що давайте, я займаюся футболом кожен день
з 2018 року будь-які проблеми тут так правильно
ми не можемо займатися футболом ми граємо у футбол
так, це правильно, тому я граю у футбол
кожен день з 2018 року, кажучи про
професійне спорядження для моїх спортивних
занять, мені потрібні рукавички, тому що я
воротар, будь-які проблеми тут схожі на
ні, тож давайте йти далі, коли я закінчу
урок спорту, я зазвичай їм чай
в чому тут проблема
так, правильно, ми не їмо чай, ми насправді
п'ємо чай, тому це помилка
, давайте виправимо це. Я зазвичай їм
банан, як Кейт з попереднього тексту, або
що ви їсте після занять спортом,
це може бути  бар снек-бар
я не знаю шматочка шоколаду чи,
мабуть, яблука чи, мабуть, правильної
їжі салати чи трохи м’яса, щоб ви могли
виправити податок, як це, давайте продовжуємо
займатися спортом, їжте здорову їжу та вивчайте
англійську, тому що це красиво  l у
чому тут проблема так
виправте слово dutiful не підходить, тому ми
не можемо сказати, що вивчення англійської мови - це
красиво  готово, давайте перейдемо далі
і пограємо в кілька ігор, щоб
ми відгадали загадки, буу, не важко
обігнати гарячу клавішу леопардовий гріх, але
перед цим давайте переглянемо назви
видів спорту, і я збираюся показати вам
картки дуже швидко спробуйте вгадати
слова добре добре, тому перше слово готове,
давайте ще раз, чи можете ви вгадати
слово так, це йога я збираюся помістити
це на дошку, щоб ви запам’ятали, тому
номер один — йога, давайте рухатися  під номером
два готовий це коротке слово, тож дозвольте мені
показати вам більше, перше слово сніг,
тому назва виду спорту правильно
сноуборд добре зроблено давайте перейдемо до
готовності ще раз і ще раз
так, це футбол правильно, тому у нас є
йога сноуборд футбол що  я
буде наступним
, ви вгадаєте, давайте спробуємо готові до
світу, давайте
і ще раз, що це за правильний
кікбоксинг, що ви думаєте
про кікбоксинг, коли я запитав вас, мабуть,
так,
тож це номер чотири, і у нас залишилося ще два,
давайте йти  це знову довге слово,
і востаннє що це за
підводне плавання Браво, добре зроблено, тож давайте прочитаємо
разом йога сноубординг футбол
кікбоксинг підводне плавання добре зроблено, а
тепер останній готовий один два три,
що це за хокей, Браво, так що зараз я
збираюся прочитати  загадки
про ці види спорту, і ви повинні відгадати,
які я описую готові, давайте йти, це
була перша, яку ми зіграли на полі
є 22 гравці 11 у якій команді вам
потрібен м'яч, щоб грати у цей вид спорту. Мета полягає в тому, щоб
забити більше голів, ніж  інша команда на
тарілці одна команда намагається вбити м'яч
в іншу парове вугілля, так що це за
вид спорту Браво, це футбол, дозвольте мені відзначити
, футбол згадано добре, давайте
перейдемо до номеру два цей вид спорту є формою
з бойового мистецтва, ви повинні
захищатися в рукавичках і шоломі під час
заняття спортом, вам також потрібен боксерський
мішок, і мета полягає в тому, щоб атакувати
суперника ударами ногами та ударами
вище талії, тож
я думаю, що це був натяк на бойове мистецтво
Браво  це кікбоксинг, добре зроблено, давайте
перейдемо до третього цього виду спорту, ви можете
займатися під водою, одягаючи гідрокостюм,
трубку і окуляри, вам також знадобляться
ласти, що це за підводне плавання. Браво,
я не згадував про це, але під водою і
окуляри, гідрокостюм і ласти ці
слова можуть допомогти  ви вгадаєте основу
підводне плавання, добре зроблено, давайте перейдемо далі, тому
номер чотири, це заняття, яке ви
можете практикувати в засніжених місцях, люди
записують сніг на підборах, використовуючи
окуляри для шолома та сноуборд, тож що це за
сноуборд,
я думаю, слово сніг може вам допомогти  але
будьте обережні, коли почуєте слово сніг
це також може бути катання на ковзанах хокей
це також може бути катання на ковзанах або лижах, тому будьте
обережні, дочекайтеся слова для
s  спеціальне спорядження, як-от сноуборд, давайте
перейдемо на п'яту позицію. Цей вид спорту командний
вид спорту, в який грають на льоду, вам потрібна ключка,
шайба, шолом, ковзани для нього. Так що
це за
хокей, Браво, нам потрібен лід, і
це командна гра, тому це так
хокей і останнє, цей тип
вправ призначений для очищення розуму
та підтримки ніг, для цього не потрібне
спеціальне обладнання, ви можете
практикувати розтяжне дихання та
розслаблятися під час гарної йоги,
щоб вам було легко вгадати  спорт
і так, скажи, і я підготував
для вас ще одну гру, давайте переглянемо якомога більше
видів спорту та якомога більше обладнання
для цього ми збираємося використовувати стрілу,
все добре, це просто іграшка це
іграшка таємна обкладинка бомба  Насправді
це таймер, який я збираюся налаштувати, щоб
ви могли продумати якомога більше слів,
дозвольте мені бути першим зі спортом,
а потім ви продовжите з
обладнанням, добре,
завдання полягає в тому, що я почну стріляти, поки
бум  працює, будь ласка, назвіть стільки ж
слова англійською мовою як можна і не
зупиняйтеся, ви не можете зупинитися під час дії бомби
, якщо ви не пам'ятаєте жодного слова
англійською, продовжуйте українською, але,
будь ласка, не зупиняйтеся,
і коли ви почуєте вибух, це означає,
що ви  потрібно зупинитися, так що я
збираюся бути першим зі спортом, а
потім ви продовжуєте з готовим спорядженням,
тому я починаю бум йога
хокей кікбоксинг бокс легка атлетика
гімнастика футбол
скібол катання на ковзанах сноуборд лижі
верхова їзда теніс настільний теніс водне
поло  підводне плавання, дайвінг, що ще допоможе мені
бокс взяти одні двері крикет квідич
баскетбол я згадав про цей волейбол
Браво,
що було складним, тепер твоя
черга
переможці за ваучерами так
спортивність чистий геній Будда Кім добре,
так що спортивне обладнання Ready Steady Go
[Сміх]
fli  сталеві баскетбольні сітки рукавички
боксерські рукавички відбити футбольний
баскетбол тенісний м'яч і записати який
костюм купальник що ще що ще
дивність скакалка ока  y antastic,
щоб ви могли порахувати, якщо можете, скільки
слів ви назвали. Я впевнений, що ви
назвали більше 10 слів і навіть 20
слів, тому дуже дякую вам за це,
ви можете продовжувати грати з цією грою, а
насправді ви цього не зробили  потрібне будь-яке спеціальне
обладнання, як-от бомба, ви можете просто
встановити таймер і спробувати назвати якомога більше слів це
ви не можете повії власність Патерно
потужність приватного Дорма Муслім ніколи не
переходив до бомбардувальників ніколи не
переходив до буу Джекі таймер
EEPROM Латта якумо  гібіскус в прямому ефірі
допоможе вам швидше запам'ятати слова
добре, давайте перейдемо далі, скажемо для вас коротку вікторину,
давайте подивимося на слова, щоб
ви могли побачити спорт чи обладнання
чи навіть люди, які займаються цими
видами спорту, подивіться
крикет  назва виду спорту щілина
- це людина боксерські рукавички це
спорядження, тому я б хотів, щоб ви зараз
розділили ці слова на три категорії
спортивні люди та спорядження, тому ще
раз подивіться на слова і розділіть їх
на три категорії  s Я дам вам 20
секунд, щоб перевірити, тож давайте
подивимося
крикет – це вид спорту, бита – це спорядження,
яке нам потрібно для крикету, щілина – це
людина, добре,
тоді переходьте до боксера, це знову людина,
і спорядження боксерські рукавички –
снорклінг  спортивний гідрокостюм - це
спорядження ковзани і парк це
також обладнання їжа м'яч - це спорт
і сноуборд це знову спорт,
тому тепер давайте попрактикуємося в деяких реченнях
, подивіться крикет що ми можемо сказати,
яке речення ми можемо сказати, наприклад
крикет  мій улюблений вид спорту це
нормально або я не можу грати в крикет чи крикет
для мене невідома гра, давайте поїдемо
з битою, наприклад, за цією таблицею у
нас поганий спорядження, і у нас
є крикет як назва спорту тому
давайте складемо речення нам потрібна пташка
грати в крикет
це дуже гарне речення давайте перейдемо
до наступного розріз
яке речення ми можемо створити я
знаю дуже відомого спортсмена в нашій
країні Сергія Бубку або ви можете сказати я
не  не знаю жодного f  amous ass давайте
рухаємося далі, у нас є боксер і боксерські
рукавички, чи можете ви створити речення, подібне до того,
що я створив для крикету, добре,
боксеру потрібні боксерські рукавички для його
діяльності або для боксу, скажімо
знову, боксеру потрібні боксерські рукавички, щоб
займатися боксом, давайте продовжимо
у нас є підводне плавання в гідрокостюмі чи можете
ви допомогти мені добре для снорклінгу вам
потрібен гідрокостюм що ще нам потрібні ласти
окуляри та трубка молодець давайте
продовжимо ковзани та шайбу якщо ми візьмемося
на ковзани ми можемо сказати хм,
нам потрібні ковзани для льоду  катання на ковзанах або нам
потрібні ковзани для хокею якщо ми подивимося на
цю комбінацію ковзани та парк
що це за
Браво це хокей то давайте
складемо речення нам потрібні ковзани та парк
для хокею молодці давайте з
футболом
легке речення мій улюблений вид спорту
футбол або я люблю грати у футбол,
мабуть, можна сказати, що я не люблю
футбол, я не можу терпіти футбол, що
це означає постійно.
ніколи не
пробував кататися на сноуборді, і це правда
про мене я ніколи не пробував кататися на сноуборді
Я боюся насправді, а
ти коли-небудь пробував кататися на сноуборді ти прийшов і
давайте переглянемо, яке спорядження нам потрібно
для футболу це легкий футбол нам
потрібен футбол хороший
добре  сноуборд, нам потрібен
сноуборд і окуляри шолом, і нам
обов'язково потрібен дуже теплий одяг,
щоб захистити себе від вітру та
низької температури, тому, як ви бачите,
у таблиці є прогалини, і я хотів би
, щоб ви заповнили цю таблицю як домашнє завдання
для  приклад подивіться давайте попрацюємо
зі словом футбол це легко я
напишу приклад на дошці так
футбол це назва виду спорту
давайте поїдемо була людина, яка грає у
футбол як ми називаємо його чи її
футболіст правильно і  давайте поговоримо про
спорядження, яке нам потрібно для футболу,
нам потрібен футбольний мяч, що ще, ймовірно,
правильний матч футбол Непальські тренери
давайте запишемо тренажери Кріс, якщо Kia в
порядку, так що на іспит  будь ласка, оскільки я дивлюся на
боксерські рукавички та боксера, як
називається спортивний бокс, молодець, тому я
хотів би, щоб ви заповнили цю таблицю,
яка повна та містить всю
необхідну інформацію про спортсменів
та обладнання, це ваше  домашнє завдання
до наступного уроку
[Музика]
і я чую дзвінок,
треба припинити дякую
за урок і до наступного разу
будь готовий з домашнім завданням
ми перевіримо стіл до побачення
[Музика]
ти